schocknachricht nach trump äußern awo &
johnson jetzt auch jens spahn am
mittwoch wurde bekannt dass der
gesundheitsminister positiv auf corona
getestet wurde
selbst die die am meisten geschützt
scheinen erwischt das virus welche
auswirkung hat seine erkrankung
ich glaube es war so ein bisschen die
schock nachricht gestern jens spahn
unser gesundheitsminister hat corona was
für signale sendet diese diagnose aus
meinen sie die leute nehmen es
wahrscheinlich jetzt noch ernster also
nicht ihr endlich das war super ich hab
heute zu sagen na jetzt also nicht alle
haben jemanden im umfeld der erkrankt
ist oder die erkrankt ist und den kann
spanien kennen wir alle und er ist
wahrscheinlich der der also einer von
denen die enorm engagiert erkämpfen
dafür diesen dieses virus zu besiegen
und jetzt ist er selber krank geworden
und ich glaube viele menschen fühlen mit
mit ihm wünsche neben schnelle genesung
und gleichzeitig merken sie ja es kommt
näher und das höre ich auch aus dem
umfeld nur viele sagen jetzt sind doch
schon einige ich auch kenne und wir
können das virus nicht sehen riechen
hören fühlen schmecken also wer wir
merken es nicht direkt wir können es nur
einen auswirkungen sehen und so wird es
konkreter also eigentlich für fünf für
die für die bevölkerung ist es eine gute
entwicklung sogar also es ist im
endeffekt zu dass corona jetzt ein
gesicht bekommt ja genau wie das ist
immer drin und die schuld immer näher es
gab aber auch andere stimmen
da hast du dich ganz besonders gestern
darüber aufgeregt die sind ja das stimmt
das ist halt so rechne ganz besondere
symbolik dass ausgerechnet der
gesundheitsminister also der mann der am
meisten dafür gekämpft hat das viele
andere kein cola bekommen jetzt selber
davon betroffen ist es zeigt dass wir
doch alle gleich sind dass wir
verwundbar sind dass wir eine
verwundbare welt eine verwundbare
gesellschaft sind und das schafft auch
unsicherheiten das schafft natürlich
auch ängste und er ist sehr
verantwortungsbewusst auch im umgang
gewesen
was die hygiene schutzmaßnahmen anging
wurde jeden tag monatelang schon fieber
gemessen und als ich erkältungssymptome
breitgemacht haben den test gemacht und
dann eben auch positiv bestätigt er ist
jetzt auch sozusagen hat sich in
häuslicher isolation durch beruflichen
bisschen hast du ein paar informationen
wie es ihm geht was er macht also das
ist alles noch milde
also hat sich wie gesagt eine häusliche
isolation begeben und jens spahn ist
kein solist sondern teamplayer also der
laden läuft trotzdem weiter ich glaube
das ist auch wichtig auch ein signal und
was da eben auch auf symbolisch
emotionaler ebene passiert ist eben auch
nicht zu unterschätzen
die menschen wollen natürlich das gefühl
haben dass wir trotzdem alles im griff
haben obwohl es viel es gibt was sich
verändert hat und vieles auch was neu
ist und man hat gestern eben gesehen
dass über alle parteigrenzen hinaus auch
gute besserung milder verlauf gewünscht
worden ist und das ist uns auch
solidarisch zusammenrücken lässt das war
so ganz tief mein eindruck auch aber es
gibt natürlich auch die schaumschläger
wie zum beispiel seitens der kfd die das
sofort auch sozusagen parteipolitisch
nutzt genutzt haben um dagegen zu halten
und die tatsache dass bei über 11.000
neue infektionen am tag mit sozusagen
auch rasanter tendenz nach oben wirklich
abgeordnete im bundestag da dafür
kämpfen dass der max masken schutz
sozusagen ja nicht stattfinden muss es
höchst bedenklich und zeigt aber auch
hoffentlich auch er auf welcher seite
wir stehen müssen und deswegen bleibt
nur gute besserung zwischen gute
genesung und wir brauchen ihn ja absolut
und ich fand es auch so erschreckend
gestern dass es dann auf einmal los ging
teilweise gerade im social media bereich
ja das bringt doch alle sich das ist
doch der beweis dass die masten quatsch
sind derzeit reich meine zeit niemand
vorher gesagt wer die maske trägt wird
definitiv kein grüner bekommen es ist
nur natürlich ein zusätzlicher schutz
den herr lang haben aber auch ein riesen
ist muss man jetzt einfach mal sagen
dass ausgerechnet der minister den wir
jetzt in der pamina am dringendsten
brauchen jetzt erkrankt wird und
natürlich er vermittelt das video ist
sagt sie den eindruck es bringt ja alles
nichts denn sicherlich hat er sich an
alle maßnahmen wenn er von den er selber
spricht seit monaten strängen dran
gehalten dass er mir gestern in den
kabinettssitzungen gesehen im größten
saal saßen alle mit einem riesenabstand
man weiß nicht wo er sich angesteckt hat
ist zeigt aber eben wieder das virus
macht kein
was geschützt nicht zu hundert prozent
auch der abstand nicht es gibt im sole
in der luft es gibt türklinken es gibt
alles mögliche wir werden einfach
niemals einen hundertprozentigen schutz
haben und dass man eben durch den fall
ihren spaniens ist das ganze virus eben
doch noch mal sehr viel näher an uns ran
gekommen
trotzdem ist es auch wichtig dass man
weiterhin natürlich die aha regel
beachtet also das ist ja nicht
wegzureden dass man das trotzdem
natürlich die maske tragen sollte
weitergehen und sie regelmäßig die hände
waschen sollte aber nicht haben aber
genug menschen geben die sagen da sie ja
gar nichts gebracht
das ist mein nächstes jahr gleich selbst
unseren gesundheitsminister erwischt
dann kann ich das doch gleich lassen ist
doch quatsch ich glaube es ist wichtig
dass davon nicht großartig beeinflussen
lassen
[Musik]